All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week and the last set of audience
questions of 20 20, very exciting. OK, first
question, David. We hear all the bluster
from Trump, special counsel, martial law.
He won lawsuits, all of this other stuff. Is
Trump genuinely going to try to physically stay
in the White House after January 20th? I think
the answer is still no. I think the answer is
still no. I know that there we reported on Trump
floating or suggesting to some some
of his aides, maybe I just won't leave
sort of thing. I think that Donald Trump
either already knows or will become convinced
by the time January 20th rolls around that it
would be really, really embarrassing for himself
to, you know, have to be escorted out of the White
House or for reports to be that he was refusing to
leave or something like that. Now, the truth
is he probably has some followers that are so
sycophantic that if Trump tried it, they would see
it as some kind of act of defiant heroism rather
than the corrosive act for the country that that
it would be. But but I do believe that, you know,
Trump's kids, I think, would all get it. Like
you can't physically try to stay. It would be
humiliating to try to do it. I don't think he's
actually going to try to do it now. Between now
and then, he will continue to insist he won.
He will continue to tweet the things he's been
tweeting and look at. Could could I maybe get this
overturned in some way? But even Donald Trump,
I am sure, recognizes that just staying there,
absent any court decision about, you know, not
accepting results or these things are all going
by the wayside every time we reach a new milestone
in the process of certifying and electors voting
and all of that, I think even Trump recognizes,
absent something tangible to say, look, this state
has flipped now or something. I don't think he's
going to physically try to do it. Now, I I admit
that as someone who covers this stuff, Trump talks
about ratings. I can imagine no greater ratings
than video of Donald Trump being forcibly removed
from the White House. But I don't believe it
will happen. It would be absolutely terrible,
terrible for for the country. I believe really
the milestone date for Trump will be January 6th.
I think on on on January 6th, Mike Pence
is planning after the official counting of
the electoral votes which have already been cast.
Remember, January 6th is just the formalization of
a joint session of the House and Senate. Counting
those votes, Mike Pence is scheduled to within
hours leave the country and go on a trip to I
think it's Poland and maybe UAE. I don't remember
exactly the countries and I would not be surprised
if Trump is even still in Washington by then.
There's rumors he may be leaving sooner for Trump
to completely disappear and maybe even abandon the
White House. I don't know. There's the idea he'll
stay in the White House and then fly to a rally on
Inauguration Day. There's the idea he'll
never return from Christmas and just stay in
Florida. There's the idea that January 6th may
be when he sort of formally gives it up and we
stop hearing from him altogether. But I believe
that he is not. If the question is, will Trump
try and consider any mechanism or manipulation
that might allow him to steal the election? The
answer is, of course, yes. And he's thought of
everything from lawsuits of different kinds,
trying to send different electors, convincing
state legislatures and governors to send different
electors. That came in one season. Voting
machines, which has some of his lawyers told him,
you can't do a martial law, was reportedly, you
know, all of these different ideas. He's morally
willing to do any of it. But I do not believe he
will physically try to stay in the Oval Office.